so if i say to you oh yes i'm having an
association right well I'm associated
when someone else is like oh yes Kimmy
and Hannah up associated together what
does that mean without actually mean
like if you say something some things
are associated well what's a way I could
use to like synonym for that substitute
for that narrative common common okay
yes or no ah ok Wow BFFs 5 ever ok yes
what else friends yes a not know each
other ok good so all these words and a
lot of that a lot of them do in fact
about their people right so what we
think about associating not people but
numbers ok what we mean is you can group
them group them in different kinds of
audits search for again here's an
example this is something we looked at
right at the end of last term under
order of operations ok six plus seven
plus four addition is associative so I
can actually say do you do 647 first or
you do seven plus 4 1st which one do i
do first no interestingly for addition
and maybe you want to put some areas you
for me it doesn't matter just like you
saw here it's up I can get the same one
no matter which one I do first so I
could do six plus seven first which is
13 phosphate right and you're going to
get this done or alternatively I could
do I could do the seven plus 4 1st if I
wanted and then add 6 in fact if i want
i can shift it up even more ways because
of the commutator law i can switch the
order here and go let's do six plus four
we might like to do since plus 4 1st why
would you do that because it was
yeah they're friends of tents are they
easy and then you just get 17 out of
that okay just a good question attention
maybe I was talking about that also
please do because as I said we've got
one we need well how about refuse your
MSS all right now this idea of the
associated wall right maybe you want to
summarize it in this way for addition
and the multiplication you can numbers
that's exactly what it is right because
brackets we've seen in order operations
then what you should do first right but
you can see it no matter where you put
the brackets you always get the same
thing just kind of nice yes correct
that's exactly right okay and I won't
write the multiplication is the same
thing if I did 6 times 7 times 4 again
you can multiply them you can do these
two pairs per store these or you can
shift them around and whatever yeah yeah
it's closely related that in fact okay
and part of like what I said before
right when you see something like this
you should treat it as a guide right
it's meant to help you remember it's
just to Memphis or memory really what
you shouldn't either you think of is
what do numbers do like if I added all
of this you still get 17 so that's the
real ball this is a wall and that's just
kind of a kindle afternoon get to help
okay